還可以提問
它也會回答你問題
但是你會發現一件事情
叫做
它回答你的問題的時候
好像前面的東西已經忘掉了
它好像沒有之前那麼聰明
沒有最開始回答你那個問題
只有那個聰明
為甚麼呢
就是我們所說的
模型的上下文是有限的
這個我們用的這些agent
整個窗口也是有限的
所以當我們在處理一個
複雜任務的時候
我們有的時候是需要把任務拆開
有的任務拆開一個窗口來做的
那當然現在很多的agent
它也會做一些事情
叫做自壓縮
就是它發現太強了之後
它會自己很聰明的去壓縮
但往往有的時候壓縮的效率比較好
就比如說它壓下來之後
就可能說最開始的時候
接待你的是一個非常聰明的一名員
用著用著用著
它工作的一天
它很累了
它非常困
那這個時候可能會
領導會讓它喝一瓶紅牛
能撐起來
那這個時候依舊不是早上接待你的人
所以很多的時候我們需要乾嘛
需要新開窗口
所以我們需要把任務去分款
去做這件事情
所以這是我們在用AI的過程中的一個
就或者說鐵吉祭詞
在過程中要學會去把這些東西去採款
那還有一點就是我們要學會去
剛才所說的開新窗口也好
當時我們在用Champware的時候
我們要學會去上下文重置
就是忘掉我們之前所有的東西
我們重新來聊聊這個問題
但現在來說的話
你用了Engine
你基本上不需要上下文重置的這個工作了
那我們前面有說到一點就是之前的時候
提示詞的發展歷程
從最開始框架型
再到李濟剛老師這種系統的工程性
再到現在基於不同的行業的這種性
那其實核心就是一個問題
就是所有的這些格式
好像對大家來說更好理解了
那更重要的是
我們在設計提示詞的時候
一定要去基於業務維度去設計
類似於說這幾個都是提示詞
你會發現有一些提示詞
長得特別像代碼形式
他就是李濟剛老師
當時很喜歡用的那種綠格式
他會對於一些
我們說文本性的呈現
或者是一些結構化的呈現
它的精准度會更高
它好像就是讓梅艾
很精准地在辭行你這個任務
因為他把這些東西
變成了一種代碼的詞意
包括我們去深圖的時候
我們可以用另外一種代碼格式
我不知道這裡有沒有程序語
就是這張格式
它可以非常準確地
就指引一張圖
甚麼地方
應該放甚麼東西
所以我們在深一些海報
或者說我們在處理一些
給客戶的營銷海報
能處接的東西的時候
我們一般會有這種方式
那圖片的精細化控制
會把像一個人一樣
一個導演一樣
去形容一張圖
那短短的話
就是我們之前
在CNAS 2.5還沒出來的時候
我們經常會做
非常複雜的這種提示詞
而且很多的時候會是英語
因為AI對於英語的識別
會比中文的識別會好一些
精神都會更高一些
在當時是這個樣子
所以這其實就是我們說
你今天你處於甚麼樣的行業
你處於甚麼樣的這樣的一個
工作的領域裡面
你要學會去探索
甚麼樣的提示詞
會對你這個工作的這種
幫助會更大
你可以通過代碼
因為它都是語言形式
它都是這種表達形式
所以你可以通過探索不同的格式
不同的形式
去看到底哪種方式
是更好的去控制你這件事情的
非常地不一樣
那還有一個點
就是說在AI交互的過程中
有非常多的問題
就類似於你今天給了他
一個提示詞
類似於我們剛才通過
剛才那個方式
生產出來了
是不是生產出來了
一個提示詞
然後用這個提示詞
出來了這份報告
你會發現這個報告
還蠻詳細的
跟我昨天給你們的
應該差不多了太多
然後你一定會在初次的裡面
去發現一個事情
叫做
它還是有點問題
你要去迭代它
那迭代應該怎麼迭代
其中會出現甚麼樣的問題
以及怎麼迭代
我們在這個裡面
會有一些說法
有點卡到的感覺
稍微再回一下
那首先這一點就是說
如果當你發現了
AI在你寫的這個提示詞
它答非所問
跟你想要輸出的內容
跟你想要的東西
差別非常大的時候
有可能出現甚麼問題
有可能就是
其中的你的目標
你的描述
你沒有讓它認識到
中間可能出現一些
起義或者各於複雜
讓AI難以一次性把握
所以在這個裡面
我們就需要去學會
一些調整的策略
就是等於說
對症下藥
你發現這個提示詞
沒有這樣的用
好像寫出來的
跟我想要的差別很大
然後它出來東西
跟我想要的東西
很不一樣的時候
但這個時候
其實就是
描述不清楚的問題
那你就需要去重申
並且簡化你的目標
你最後要的到底
是不是一份報告
你到底要的是一份文檔
你要的是一份甚麼東西
你要把這個目標
再去強化
讓它說清楚
那第二個就是
我們所說的
那輸出的章節
包括段落的順序
不合邏輯
或者是這個東西
沒有那麼的
按你的方式來
那你可能就是要在裡面
去加上一些
工作流程的引導
你不單單要告訴他
AI要輸出一份甚麼東西
你要告訴他
怎麼去輸出
你的過程是怎麼樣的
那第三就是我們所說的
對輸出格式的要求不對
類似於說
像剛才的過程中
我們有一些地方
我是希望它輸出的
像是表格
我希望它輸出的
像是這種SBG圖
那我怎麼樣去說呢
就等於說
我們要把這種輸出格式
讓它更加的清晰
更加的明確
就是你想要甚麼東西
你就一定要把這個事情
說得更清楚
那同時還有一些就是
我們所說的這種背景信息
為甚麼有的時候你讓AI寫的一篇文章
你覺得它在隨你
因為你給它的背景信息不夠多
有的時候就是我們說
我們說AI沒有辦法叫
還是那句老話叫巧婦難為
無影之吹
當你的內容不夠多的時候
當你的那些具體的信息不夠多的時候
它就很容易去給你虛構
但是虛構的東西其實不是你想要的東西
所以這其實是上下文的問題
它沒有辦法給到你充足的上下文
所以它沒辦法給你做出一盤好菜了
斷到你面前
所以你會發現一件事情
提示詞它是一個
也是一個重要的
就是一門一門課程
如果你把它單的拎出來
它是一門大的課程
就是它會涉及到怎麼去洗
怎麼去優化
怎麼去乾
怎麼去看它裡面的問題
好
提示詞我們就說到這裡
我們再講一個更重要的
在現在來說
可能大家會覺得提升診
哎呀
市面上也流傳了非常多人
在說提示詞不重要
但是實際上我們這裡在用的人
我們就知道提示詞還非常重要
所以把這一塊帶給大家
那接下來講一個
可能大家在上半年到今天
一直會聽到的一個詞叫SKILL
有人經常刷到嗎
有的話可以給我舉個手
經常會刷到SKILL
但知道SKILL是甚麼意思的
請舉個手
有很多人知道
有英語人知道
後來說很多人
OK好
那SKILL其實如果
因為今天在座上大家都不知道
都是從事這個行業的
我們簡單的說
我們可以把它理解為
它是一個進階的提示詞
它是一個更複雜的提示詞
它怎麼去表達呢
它其實是一個文件夾的形式去表達
你今天你去看
類似說昨天我負載文件夾裡面給你們的東西
它其實是一個甚麼東西
它其實就是一個文件夾裡面
有非常多的文件
它就是一個SKILL
它只要在它的文件夾裡面
有一個文件叫做SKILL.MD
它這個東西就算一個SKILL
我給大家打開開一看
比如說昨天我給大家打開的這個資料
我給大家這個裡面
其實有一些SKILL在
類似於這個
你會發現它裡面有個甚麼文件
就是SKILL.MD
MD是一個maktown的格式
也就是我們所說的AI
最能理解的一個文本格式
它有點像Word
有點像這個我們所說的PDF
你可以理解的就是一種這種格式的類型
那它裡面記錄的都是文字
所以就這樣的一個方式
那你會發現它這個文件夾裡面
這樣的一個文件夾就可以稱為
它是一個SKILL
那在這個裡面
它裡面還會放
類似說很多的復加文件
那這些復加文件
有的是maktown格式
有的是yout格式
所以不同的這些格式
它其實充當了不同的作用
那甚麼作用
所有你們不需要關心
你們只需要關心
SKILL它就是一個複雜的
更複雜一點的提示詞
它能夠指引AI或者Engine
能復完成你的
按你的要求
去完成你的任務就可以了
這樣的一個事情
然後它具體的表現
就是一個文件夾的格式就OK
然後在這裡面
我們看到的就是說
為甚麼從年頭到現在
SKILL一直被大家所重視
其實裡面涉及到幾個點
就是首先SKILL
它可以去做為一個偏好的記錄
例如說我今天
我要去做我的字面題
我每天要寫的東西
是不是一定像是要從
我嘴巴裡面說出來的這種感覺
所以我做了一個SKILL
我可以把這些東西
全部記錄進去
每次寫文章的時候
我只需要給它想法
它就可以按我的方式
去表達出來
因為裡面記錄了
我對於語言的偏好
這是我們所說的SKILL
第一個作用
第一個作用就是效率的提升
大家還記得昨天我發給大家
SKILL
就是做鄉檢驗的那種
以前的時候
你做鄉檢驗
是不是要經歷一個
非常長的複雜的流程
到現在
你有了這樣的SKILL之後
你完全可以通過一張
我們所說的參考圖
加一張產品圖
直接調用
半個小時就可以出
可能你要雅雇一個人
花一周的時間做出來的一套圖
所以它可以達到一個流程的效率提升
第三
它可以成為一個
甚至一個複雜的SKILL
它可以變成一個業務的
甚至我們可以說
就頂一個業務門了
它到底怎麼做到呢
等一下給大家看一下
但在這個之前
我很想教大家兩件事情
就是SKILL這件事情
大家理解到現在
不需要理解的那麼深
你們只需要知道它
是一個文件夾
裡面有個SKILL.MD
這個SKILL.MDG商業的說明書
去告訴我AI
應該怎麼去執行這個任務
就OK了
那對於大家來說
更應該掌握的是這兩個技能
第一個技能叫做
如何去找到一個好用的SKILL
我相信大家也在小文書上面
經常刷到一件事情
這個老師說
我做了一個非常好用的SKILL
他能幫我完成甚麼樣的任務
那個老師就說
這個SKILL
我發現了一個甚麼樣的SKILL
特別好用
那下面就會發現有很多人在評論
老師這個SKILL叫甚麼名字
老師這個SKILL能不能發給我
其實你們完全不需要上出
因為當你今天在網上看到了一個
別人覺得好用的SKILL的時候
你怎麼快速的去找到它
你就只需要看它在整個的
類似過程中
一定會露出它的名字
當你有了這個名字之後
你直接去一個網站叫Dipop
上面你就能收到
一般來說都能收到這個SKILL
舉個例子
類似於說
我今天做了一個
我在網上看到了一個SKILL
叫做SKILL Creator
然後你直接這樣收
有的時候也能收到這個SKILL
你只要知道它的名字
你只要上Google
一般來說都能收到
如果收不到
因為有些名字不像這麼的直接
那它可能會有一些混橋的網頁
或者乾嘛
你在後面加多一個詞叫做Dipop
它就能去搜出來這個鏈接
然後你就能看到
就是直接進來
這個三秒
那當然也會有很多的
就是Dipop Creator的
就是類似說同名的東西
所以這個時候你就要去篩選
但很核心的一個搜索的方式
其實就這麼簡單
你知道了這個名字
你搜一個Gipop在後面加一個委嘴
它基本上就能在上面去收到
這樣的一個SKILL
那Gipop是一個甚麼網站呢
這個網站很厲害啊
我們說叫集人類智慧一致大乘的一個網站
上面有非常多前人做的代碼
以及一些知識庫的東西
全部在裡面
所以大家有可能
所以我們這個像我們
雖然我不是一個程序員
但我有的時候也會逛一逛他
因為就會看到大多數的人會去
線上面去做甚麼樣的一些新的內容
新的產品
新的程序
甚至像現在SKILL很流行的之後
我們就會去上面看
最近很流行的SKILL去測試一下
就會有這樣的一個情況
但這個技巧是一個非常好用的技巧
等於說你今天去刷到了一個小紅書的博主
他說他用一個SKILL解決了甚麼樣的問題
那他沒有告訴你這個SKILL在哪裡下載的時候
你就去看他這個SKILL叫甚麼名字就好了
然後把他的名字加HIP HOP去HIP HOP上面搜
你就能得到這個東西
然後如果你今天不知道在做一件事情的時候
有甚麼樣的SKILL好用
你覺得我解決嗎
就是你也不知道有哪個SKILL的好用
然後也不知道有甚麼名字的時候
那這個時候怎麼辦
你可以讓AZIAN幫你去找他
我們在AZIAN裡面有一個很好用的東西
就打開你的
打開你的這個WOBALID
然後在你們的這個專家技能連接器這個地方
我們現在安裝一個SKILL
技能
有看到嗎
大家同步操作一下
這個地方就是一些小的操作的地方
然後在這裡面有個地方叫SKILL HUB
然後裡面搜一下SKILL HUB
然後裡面搜一下WOBALID
因為有些人可能電腦預先裝了
有些人電腦沒有預先裝
只有很多個
應該都差不了太多
然後去選擇排行前面的這個WOBALID
然後把它的加號點上
進來的時候
專家技能連接器這個裡面點技能
然後進入到SKILL HUB
然後上面點FINE
你就能出來FINE SKILL SKILL
然後把它加到你的本地
這一步做好你舉個手
網絡問題嗎
一個SKILL其實大小
基本上大多數的SKILL大小都不會特別大
它不像一個APP一樣
大多數的SKILL
它以前都是一個簡單的SKILL.MP加上一些內容
搞定到這一步的舉個手
對好多重名的你就選一個就好了
其實大差不差的那起來做
對
OK
好
現在已經蠻多人OK了
然後新建任務
大家知道怎麼把SKILL掉出來嗎
對
斜槓
然後
找到剛才你已經下載下來的這個FINE SKILL
好
然後
你可以告訴他一件事情
如果
類似於說
幫我找一個去AI位的SKILL
你如果有自己的工作
你就做自己的工作就好了
類似於說
你幫你找一個寫文章的幫你找一個做做營銷的幫你找一個甚麼樣的都OK
然後點一下Enter就OK了
那你就會看到一件事情通過FINE SKILL
它就會幫你出來一些東西
類似於說
我這裡已經有一個好好的給大家看一下結果
你們可以一邊操作
操作玩的在等的過程中可以看一看我這個結果
那它就會告訴你找到不少好東西
幫你整理了最新的自媒體
因為我當時給他的是幫我找一些自媒體運營的SKILL
他就會幫你把這個東西搞下來
那在這個裡面有一些點你會看到下載量跟星數
那在這個裡面我們一般來說會做一件事情
就是會去看它的下載量以及STAR數
那在這個地方沒有給我STAR數
因為我們說GIPPOP上面最重要的一個指標
其實是STAR這個指標
也就是多少人收藏了你這個倉庫
那收藏就代表了一件事情叫做任可
也就是很多的人覺得你這個東西好用
所以認可了你
那我們有的時候就會去看它的下載數以及STAR數
然後基於這個東西讓它去給我排行
類似說把排在上面的東西去給我
就是我們所說的我們去嘗試看哪一個更好用
所以這件事情核心是在於甚麼
當你不知道有甚麼樣的SKILL
可以解決你想要解決的這個問題的時候
你可以通過加載我們剛才所說的
FiveSKILL這個SKILL去進行搜索
你看它這個地方就已經開始把我搜了一圈了
為甚麼它知道我的
對它把我名字打下去
我也不知道為甚麼
因為我覺得
WinBody的Hoties就有的時候很奇怪
就是我明明沒有搞記憶
它就記住我的東西了
那它就開始那些說
HumanLizers
Human Financial各種
然後我那你會發現缺少了甚麼
我剛才說的排行
那我會告訴他這個數量不夠
然後同時請你按那個大樹幫我做排行
大樹出來了
然後它就會再去搜索一圈
那你會看到
接下來它就給了我10個
然後每一個後面應該都會有SKILL這個事情
然後大家看到這裡有看到一個東西嗎
叫你消耗了多少
其實就是消耗了你的積分
然後你會發現它會告訴你去AI的技能完整排行
有哪些
然後有HumanLizers這個有安裝的人
有SKILL有1081
然後這個有596
然後231
51610等等
那怎麼去安裝呢
其實你就告訴他
假設你覺得哪個是你聽起來比較靠譜的
類似於說我現在已經安裝了1
我現在要安裝2
請你幫我安裝2到本地
我覺得這兩天跟大家這樣操作完
大家會覺得就用AI真的是一件很簡單的事情
因為就是一直在跟它調整的
沒有甚麼特別的技能
純純脆脆都是一些非常
叫甚麼
就是你們可能不知道
Agent是能幫你解決這個問題的
你們可能都覺得手動要去把這個東西安裝到本地
昨天也是有個同學問我
怎麼把我那個SKILL安裝到本地
其實就把那個SKILL撥到
你的Word里裡面去
然後告訴他幫我安裝到本地
然後他每次就可以在這個裡面把它調用出來
就這麼簡單
好
他就會告訴我安裝完成
其實我現在就是可以去把
你看他有兩個了
這裡有一個去AI位
應該還有一個
我看一下他在哪裡
一般來說有個問題叫甚麼
叫做你新安裝的SKILL
在這個地方是不會呈現的
這個時候你要做一件事情叫重啓
這是把它推出來
再進去它才會加載這個SKILL
OK
這也是一個操作的細節
有人會問我
所以講到這裡
我已經
大家的這個跑出來SKILL
已經跑出來了
跑出來的檢局的時候
就是就是有說幫你們找到一些SKILL
有一些不多
可能在這跑的過程中沒關係
那找到了之後
不一定是好用的
我要跟大家講
就是有一些東西
其實還是要基於你自己的需求
去進行一些改造的
所以所以我說我覺得說這個部分
還是蠻重要
你要自己學會去改造一些東西
然後你看就是很簡單
你去HIPPOP上面去收收到了之後
幫我安裝一下這個SKILL到盤地
就OK了
那這一步其實就是我們所說的
關於SKILL其中的一個最重要的地方
就是你怎麼去找到一個好用的SKILL
然後第二步叫做
第二步叫做怎麼去做一個SKILL
就是今天你會發現你找到的東西都不好用的情況下
你怎麼給自己去做一個這樣的好用的工具
那我們說做SKILL
其實也很簡單
我們把這些東西都理解的相對簡單一點
跟我們做提示詞是一樣的事情
那當時我們做提示詞
剛才跟他講了怎麼做一個提示詞
先把任務講一遍
講完之後跟他battle幾輪
battle完了之後
讓他幫我把提示詞輸出出來
對不對
那做SKILL邏輯有點像
但過程有點不同的是
你要先跑完一個任務
就等於說你要先跑一個任務
讓他從頭到尾乾完
類似於說你今天想讓他做一份營銷的方案
你今天想要讓他去幫你跑一張圖
你今天想要幫你去出一份甚麼樣給客戶的一份報告
你要讓他從頭到尾跑完
當你發現他跑了這份報告非常不錯的時候
那這個時候就可以跟他說一句話
把我們剛才所做的所有事情做成一個SKILL
當我每次輸入一個甚麼東西的時候
都能做一份相同的內容
其實非常簡單
然後在這個過程中最重要的是甚麼
就是一定是要去做
就當他給你這些東西是一定完全靠譜的情況下
你才去做這些事情
不然他會把一些不好的東西記錄進去
我也給大家看一下他的整個過程
好比說前段時間
我經常會有些朋友來問我一些生意問題
因為我們做策劃的嘛
做策略的
然後我們有朋友就是想去開
去開線下的精量店
有沒有想之前的時候特別想去做一些精量的
就是這種線下酒館
然後或者是咖啡生意的同學
有的話可以舉個手啊
有沒有這樣想法的人
當時他覺得問了我一個問題
叫做
哎呀
就是我在甚麼地方開一家這樣的精量酒館
你覺得有沒有搞得到
他經常會問我一些這樣的一些想法
那我當時其實我內心是有一些判斷的
但你也知道啊
跟朋友之間聊這個天
你越不讓他做他就越想做這些事情
對不對
所以我不能以我的角度去告訴他這件事情
可能大概率是搞不成的
那為甚麼呢
那其中怎麼去分析呢
那我就會想說
那我呢
因為他經常會問我這些問題
那我會就想說
能不能他每次問我的時候
我都能通過一個skill
出一份看起來比較專業的報告給他
打消他一些念頭
或者是去幫他加強一些
他可能應該補足的地方
然後你會看到我跟AI的溝通
我有一個朋友
他特別想開一下精量酒館
我想說服他用一份方案
但是也不瞎並論
就幫他分析清楚
甚麼樣的內容會好一點
然後他就會去思考
思考完了之後就是說
首先財務部分
最核心的三件事情是
初始投入
然後模型等等
他中間應該引掉了很多東西
在這個過程中
他會告訴我
比如說好問題
幫朋友做決策
最有效的方式
不是幫他下結論
而是把關鍵變量全部鋪開
然後他就通過一張圖
幫我把這件事情
全部亮出來
然後上面是整體框架
一市場的分析
二是產品的定位
三是宣次與空間
是財務模型
比如說運營體系等等
這些東西做完了
好
然後假設
我覺得他這個東西做的
說的是對的
假設我覺得
他說的這個東西還不錯
那我怎麼把它包裝成一個SQ
你會看到我的畫面很簡單
我希望把這個流程沈澱成一個SQ
當我今天輸入一件我想做的小生意的時候
你可以通過問我幾個問題
然後乾嘛也好
就是做一份報告
建一個問題
交放到我的桌面
就這麼簡單
你就可以做一個SQ出來
但是在這個裡面
你要加載一個甚麼東西
也是像我們剛才一樣
我們在搜SQ的時候
我們要加載甚麼SQ
叫FindSQ
就是找SQ這個SQ
那今天我要做一個SQ
怎麼讓他說遵守一個
比較好的原則去做出來這個SQ呢
那我們也會加載一個SQ
叫SQ Create
這個SQ應該來說
在這個裡面也是有的
你們也可以收得到
類似說像這個技能的SQ Hub裡面
你收CREATE
C-R-A-T-O-R
它應該就會出來
OK的有沒有
好可能還要前面加SQ
是不是對
在中間的SQ Hub裡面
有非常多SQ Reader
隨便找一個加載去
然後大家可以嘗試一下
就是用它去做一個SQ出來
這裡就是說你們可以
這一步大家做完了嗎
做完了請舉個手
就是把SQ Creator
加到自己的電腦裡面去
OK好
然後我們點新建任務
依舊還是要選擇工作空間
然後把SQ Creator調出來
因為前面的那個溝通的部分
我就不讓它做的
就直接告訴它
你今天有甚麼樣的想法
你讓它幫你做一個SQ出來
就OK了
但是你還是前提是甚麼
是你這個想法一定是充足的清楚
就是能夠非常充足的
跟它表達清楚
這個SQ才能這樣做出來
大家有找不到SQ Creator
這個SQ嗎
我看到好像有些人找不到
首先第一點是
專家技能連接器裡面的這個技能
大家點進去
然後在SQ Hub裡面
這個地方輸入SQ Creator
其實對於D&I來說很多的操作是很簡單的
難的點是在于思考
難的點是正好去把這些事情想清楚